jean
le téléjournal de radio canada
ce soir 1952 en ontario découverte
d'uranium source d'énergie atomique
un succès numéro un au palmarès laisse
le white cloud pride avec monsieur
émotions j'en aurai découverte de
lorient tissu lavable et sans repassage
la célèbre strip teaseuse les lis saint
cyr est accusé d'en montrer trop elle
convainc les juges et les jurés que son
métier est un art
elle gagne son procès à washington mort
de falla le chien fidèle du président
roosevelt aux états unis toujours ike
eisenhower est élu président
les cinq juges belgian célèbrent leurs
18 ans en même temps en egypte chute du
roi farouk en angleterre mort du roi
georges 6 la princesse elisabeth lui
succède déjà à helsinki finlande se
déroulent les 15e jeux olympiques
couronnement de la première miss univers
une finlandaise de 18 ans a remis kuzel
la médaille de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur française est décerné à
marlene dietrich pour ses efforts durant
la guerre la révolution éclate à cuba
batista remplace la constitution de 1940
par le statut de gouvernement
la canalisation du saint-laurent ouvre
le fleuve à la navigation maritime de
l'océan atlantique aux grands lacs
baptême du premier sous-marin atomique
américain le nautilus le premier costume
de bain scraps tâche à vince fait son
apparition ou firmament de l'amade
monseigneur paul emile léger est nommé
cardinal
les premières photos de soucoupe volante
ou objets volants non identifiés sont
prises au massachusetts aux états unis
le premier jet à passagers comète vient
d'être inaugurée le 6 septembre 1952
le premier ministre du canada le très
honorable louis st-laurent prononce le
discours d'inauguration de la télévision
canadienne
mesdames et messieurs le très honorable
louis saint laurent dans l'histoire de
notre pays
le début d'un service canadien en
télévision
nous savons par l'expérience que
d'autres pays en ont fait que la
télévision exercera une influence
prodigieuse sur la vie d'un grand nombre
de familles elle produira certainement
un effet considérable sur les jeunes
explique alain atteindre du fait que la
télévision apportera chaque jour de
vivre image d'antan de foyers elle
deviendra une très grande force sociale
cette force peut être préjudiciable à la
nation ou lui être très profitable au
canada nous avons décidé qu'il fallait
exploiter la télévision dans le dessin
d'enrichir notre vie nationale qu'il
fallait l'adapter dit positif et des
moyens qu'exigent les conditions
canadiennes afin d'assurer aux canadiens
les programmes canadiens qui leur
conviennent
ce nouveau service vous fournira
sûrement bien d occasion d'occuper et de
charmer vos loisirs votre barre il
ouvrira aux talents canadiens un vaste
champ d'initiatives nouvelles il devra
aiguisé en nous le sens de nos
ressources créatives
le canada dispose ainsi d'un nouveau
moyen de s'extérioriser notre télévision
devra nous ouvrir de nouveaux horizons
sur mer aspects de la vie canadienne et
de la sorte nous aider à mieux
comprendre mieux comprendre les uns les
autres
de même qu'elle ne reflétera nos moeurs
et nos idéaux canadien
de même elle devra nous aider à
considérer avec sympathie la vie et
l'activité créatrice des autres nations
elle devra aider à la vie familiale et
nationale canadienne de donner tous ses
fruits
telles sont les bus on envisage un en
autorisant la société radio canada et
inaugurer ce service je sais vous
voudrez vous joindre à moi pour exprimer
à la société en notre nom à tous les
soirs fervent que nous formons pour elle
au moment où elle aborde cette vaste
tâche